breaking news die tramps positiv auf
corona getestet sind in quarantäne
gute besserung insider die das paar
kennen rätseln zwar jetzt wie der
präsident das virus auf seine frau
übertragen konnte aber das geht uns
nichts an finde ich selbst für trump ist
es offensichtlich schwer die
infektionskette nachzuvollziehen aber
hat einen verdacht man könnte sich
angesteckt haben bei angesteckt haben
bei polizisten oder bei soldaten die
auch als sicherheitspersonal mitunter in
der nähe sind und präsident hatte mehr
oder minder wörtlich gesagt da wird
gegrüßt wird am abend da wird geküsst
das sind bitten die an uns herangetragen
werden und die schlagen wir dann auch
nicht mehr ab ist klar es muss schlimm
sein
alle drei meter steht ein polizist und
wirtschaft die zunge inhalt stecken er
regiert jetzt heißt es aus dem ofen home
office und die große frage lautet
natürlich was bedeutet das alles für den
wahlkampf in den usa muss zb das nächste
tv duell gegen beiden abgesagt werden
ich sage hoffentlich denn das erste am
dienstag für einfach nur furchtbar
katastrophe donald und yoda wie ich sie
seitdem nennen
die zwei von der bröl abfuhr haben uns
allen anderthalb stunden lebenszeit
geklaut es war wirklich ein tiefpunkt in
der geschichte der debattenkultur
erkenntnisgewinn 0 fremdschäm faktor
1000 hier eine zusammenfassung der
wichtigsten argumente dafür braucht man
halt doch einfach mal die schnauze das
jetzt nicht direkt elegant formuliert
aber mir gefällt es übrigens steckt
hinter dem ganzen gebrüder eine klare
strategie donald trump weiß ja er hat
angesichts der lage in den usa keine
argumente mehr
also macht er im studio den wilden affen
ne ganz kalkuliert
schreit rabatt dazwischen und dann mehr
kann alle über den schlechten moderator
und kaum noch über den unfassbar
schlechten präsidenten
solche duelle brauchen einen live
faktencheck das kann ja jeder trottel
jeden mist behaupten
die trump über beides angebliche pläne
zum klimaschutz
joe biden wird als präsident persönlich
alle kühe umbringen sagt ausgerechnet
der mann der jeden tag eine ganze herde
kühe im burger formwechsel abonniert
dabei sich im weißen haus ja auch auf
mehrmalige nachfrage wollte trump im
duell keinen friedlichen machtwechsel
garantieren oder sich von der radikalen
gewaltbereiten rechten distanzieren denn
die braucht er ja noch für den kommenden
bürgerkrieg falls er doch überraschend
verliert gar keine skrupel mehr der mann
ja und joe biden war beim duell dabei
hat teilgenommen wenn man ganz ehrlich
ist hat beiden genau zwei trümpfe im
ärmel
er ist nicht donald trump und erlebt
noch nur halt schon sehr lange so
erzählte er vor kurzem dass er bereits
seit 180 jahren dem senat angehören und
die pointe ist das stimmt sogar so und
wer hat jetzt gewonnen bei diesem tv
duell
jeder der es nicht geguckt hat wirklich
jeder oder was sagen die medien kollegen
die schlimmste debatte die es je gegeben
hat spektakel an beleidigungen
unterbrechungen hier war die rede von
einer brennenden müllkippe von einem
zugunglück zu so aggressiv mehr absurd
chaotisch erweise schätze das thema
einer wirtshausschlägerei
[Applaus]
egal jetzt die schlechte nachricht trump
fans wollen ihnen genauso sehen kämpfen
im schlamm
die stört ja auch gar nicht was die new
york times gerade über den steuerzahler
tram schreibt nämlich das ja keine
steuern zahlt also jedenfalls keinen
cent einkommensteuer in zehn von 15
jahren wobei 2016 muss der tatsächlich
insgesamt 750 dollar bezahlen
der milliardär deswegen ist ja jetzt
auch pressesprecher des neuen vereins
der unschuldig vom finanzamt verfolgten
ja das finanzamt behandelt alles
schlecht dafür ist es ja das finanzamt
mein gott was hat der immer angegeben
mit seinem reichtum und jetzt plötzlich
ist er angeblich total verschuldet
wirklich von über 420 millionen dollar
schulden ist die rede dass die kommende
scheidung von mueller ja noch gar nicht
mit eingerechnet da ist ja fast schon
ein fall für sie wissen schon raus aus
den schulden mit peter zwegat hilft aziz
ohne kohle
erstens verschafft ihr einen überblick
über deine aktuelle finanzielle
situation
zweitens erwerbe notwendiges und
grundlegendes wissen kompetenzen und
beachte ratschläge und tipps und
drittens beachten die laufenden ausgaben
ist doch klar
peter zwegat schwerster fall donald
trump der erste präsident seit nixon der
sich weigert seine steuererklärung zu
veröffentlichen da ist er in
wirklichkeit vielleicht ein wahnsinnig
schlechter geschäftsmann oder doch ein
wahnsinnig guter steuerhinterzieher
viele seiner hotels und golfanlagen
schreiben laut new york times seit
jahren tiefrote zahlen
gleichzeitig soll trump aber auch im
zuge seiner tv show the apprentice
friseurbesuche von der steuer abgesetzt
haben und das in höhe von 70.000 dollar
fern richtig gehört
70.000 dollar pro jahr abgesetzt 70.000
für diese friese hier das einzige was
noch schlechter frisiert ist als tramp
ist eine steuer gut muss ich fairerweise
dazusagen 70.000 klingt jetzt nur für
den laien viel ich kann da keine steine
schmeißen für mich arbeiten ja auch
jeden tag drei leute nur an meiner
frisur
so ist perfekt trump gegen beiden was
für ein furchtbares tv duell
was lernen wir daraus für die kommenden
duelle wenn welche kommen wie kriegt man
die krawall opas besser in den griff
matthias matschke ist schulleiter am
kollege berufskolleg berlin-neukölln
legendäre brennpunktschule herr matschke
was wäre ihr tipp als erfahrener
pädagoge naja dazwischenhauen direkte
man immer auf die zwölf
klingt hart es aber so beziehen jahr
will der tiere so nun problemschüler wie
dem donald darf sie keine sekunde den
rücken zu gerät ist wirklich
unabhängigen der kanzel froh sein wenn
ich mit kot schweisgut dazwischenhauen
das hat der fox moderator versucht ja
aber wie wie eine waldorfschule zu tun
halt magst du dir vielleicht auch mal
ausreden lassen
die träger so liebt es absolut
erbärmlich wie dem kollegen unterrichten
ist beim lask ua question er kriegt
ausschlag an libyen vor kassierten aber
das ist auch kein lehrer wissen sie
nicht bei uns machen
gero grobe du hörst jetzt oft zum arzt
rät ich dein handy kaputt empfängt eine
mutter oder umgekehrt kann für aussuchen
denn ist in ruhe im karton gut das hebt
jetzt aktuelle niveau auch nicht direkt
vor rügen niveau der gymnasiasten moment
mehr niveau an mit dem freizeit nur
unterrichtseinheit hat nur ein ziel das
der lehrer leben wieder rauskommt punkt
um donald trump ist offensichtlich nicht
mehr bespielbar und der partner
vorgeschichte ich erinnere nur an die
duelle mit frau clinton wissen dieses
noch immer wenn sie gerade mal hat er
sich so von hinten
die wand wie sie nicht kleine miese
flitz biete also ganz ehrlich so nach
einiges schmeißt nach der neunten klasse
raus und gibt die band autoscooter ab
gute idee aber was macht jetzt der
moderator vom nächsten duell mit doch
ihr sagt harte erbarmungslose arte micro
abdrehen rausschmeißen feierabend das
geht wohl nicht er ist ja der präsident
wäre gut denn heute brief der eltern die
sind tot weil der brief an seine frau
die kann ich lesen spaß aber wirklich
noch mal ganz konkret was macht man wenn
einer einfach nie aufhört dazwischen zu
labern
wenn einer ganz kalkuliert immer weiter
rum brüllt ohne punkt und komma ohne
rücksicht auf verluste wenn einer sich
gar nicht mehr an die konventionen eines
zivilisierten gesprächs help und einfach
eben ist das jetzt pädagogik stimmt so
wie wir haben ja corona doch matthias
matschke
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mimen ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und liegt - wollt dann abonniert
jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist nie mehr stellen
[Musik]